SAM SHANK: Hi, I'm Sam Shank,
and I'm CEO and co-founder.
And I try and keep everything
nice and clear for Justin to
do great coding.
JUSTIN SCHULTZ: Yeah,
I'm Justin Schultz.
I'm the Android lead
at HotelTonight.
I am responsible for building
the phone app, the tablet app.
I manage our Android team and
interact with our design team
and our various teams to make
sure that the Android app is
beautiful and working
perfectly.
SAM SHANK: This is my third
online travel start-up, and
the idea for HotelTonight
started when I was doing the
second one.
And I found out I was on my
mobile phone more than I was
on my computer at home.
And I said, why isn't there a
good way to book a hotel on
your smartphone?
And so I thought about what the
mobile use case is, and
it's about last minute, and
it's about booking in the
moment, and so we came
up with HotelTonight.
JUSTIN SCHULTZ: I started at
HotelTonight in February of
2012, and I think that there
were something like 400,000
downloads at that point.
I think we're at around
1.6 million now.
So we've seen, obviously,
explosive
growth in the last year.
We've also completely
redesigned the app.
Really since we've implemented
things like the action bar and
the fragments and really adhered
to a lot of the Google
design guidelines, we've seen
that growth certainly
exponentially--
we've seen exponential growth,
really, since really adhering
to a lot of those
good practices.
SAM SHANK: So with Android, it
was just a matter of time
until we had the resources to
be able to invest in the
tablet support.
We're really pleased with
the results both in the
performance of it as well as
the uptake from our users.
JUSTIN SCHULTZ: As you can see,
just right here, we've
got our market list.
It lists the various markets
in which we sell hotels.
You can see we've got these big
beautiful photos in a grid.
We've got a country selector
here that quickly allows folks
to jump to a particular country
and see inventory in
that country.
And as I mentioned, we also use
the drawer pattern here.
So this is something that I
actually took from last year's
Google I/O. The sliding drawer
pattern is very slick.
And so we stole that.
And we're-- you can tell that
we're using the action bar
paradigm here as well.
And I'll actually just scroll
down to San Francisco here.
I think we've got
some inventory.
San Francisco will list a kind
of a similar grid interface.
And again we're using fragments
here that allow us
to very easily modify things
like the layouts.
And in fact, one of my favorite
features is we
recently implemented expandable
notifications with
the ability to like or
dislike a hotel.
So it's just a very
quick action.
After you've stayed at a hotel,
the next day at 2
o'clock, you'll receive an
expandable notification that
just quickly asks, did
you like the hotel?
Did you not like the hotel?
And upon tapping on that
notification, you have the
opportunity to actually add
some additional comments.
That's an optional step.
But that's a really
slick feature.
And it definitely improved our
conversion rate on getting
those reviews from customers
because it's just so fast and
easy for them.
So we've got--
again leveraging these
big beautiful
photos for the hotels.
I think the photos are one
of the features that our
customers like most
about the app.
We've got these really rich,
really nice photos of the
room, of the lobby, of
the bar very often.
And so folks tend to really
enjoy these big photos.
And we leverage this on both the
phone and the tablet app.
We've also implemented this
great new map using the new
Maps v2 API.
And this map has some great
features like the ability to
tilt, the ability to rotate.
And in fact, once we get to a
particular zoom level, we'll
even see a 3D rendering of the
buildings, so that's been a
really fun feature
on the phone.
So since launching our tablet
app a couple of months ago,
we've actually seen some
enormous growth.
Greater than 50% of our recent
growth, since launching the
app, has actually come
from tablets.
And our fourth most frequently
used device now is actually
the Nexus 7 device.
So that's been great.
We're seeing a lot of
momentum in the
tablet market, obviously.
And we wanted to stay ahead of
the bell curve technically and
really build an app that worked
great on all devices,
and especially some of the
newer, nicer tablets like the
Nexus 7 and the Nexus 10.
SAM SHANK: We're really
excited about
what's next for Android.
Justin and his team have some
really exciting things coming
next that we can't tell
you about now.
But stay tuned, and in the
meantime, get the free
HotelTonight app.
And I hope you guys find a way
to book a hotel tonight soon.